all right what else you got jen um
i know you got the uh the princess pizza
on yeah
yeah that's a sad one you want to take i
sent this to you guys princess pizza
they're not shutting down they're just
under different management yeah so
after the uh racist statements were
resurfaced with both the owners which is
a
father and son duo they actually stepped
down i believe it was
saturday they announced on instagram
that day-to-day
management would no longer be taken over
by them it would be taken over by
somebody else
email talking [ __ ] like when i looked at
the race comments a lot i think the
photo was
a female but then the account belonged
to the owner
so it could have been like his wife or
yeah there's a lot of uh complaints of
the customer service
and the racist stuff was more towards uh
asians right like they called like one
lady a yellow dog
a yellow dog a mongol a mutt yeah yeah
listen that pizza is so good every time
if every time i went in there they
called me a cracker and spit in my face
i'd be cool
i don't care they can spit in my face
and call me white devil
food is delicious he goes uh i called
you a mutt which means coward i called
you a yellow dog which means coward i
called you a mongrel which is what you
are
you aren't there [ __ ] you're on the
camera you [ __ ] fool
what were they thinking who's that lady
well that's the that's the avatar i
don't know who
the woman is i assume that it was like
maybe his wife
because maybe she's the one who set up
the yelp account at one point it's like
if i see you tell me where you're at
i'll [ __ ] you up i'll break your jaw
yeah he made fun of a lot of the uh
protesters too he
posted a joke on his instagram story
saying like why did the
uh protest across the street to get ran
over and he was talking about black
lives matter
so it was it was a lot of different [ __ ]
that was coming out not
fantastic pizza but uh
i'm already thinking fellas they're cool
out here in california
i mean i don't know they wouldn't be
nice to me it's
very interesting though because uh last
sunday not
yesterday but the prior week when i got
back from west palm beach
my sister and i went to go get uh prince
street pizza
we went got a couple slices and they got
our order wrong so i went back and told
them like hey you guys are missing this
and gave us this and said this
the guy said oh i'm so sorry for the uh
inconvenience here take a whole
pepperoni pizza for free
and me taking i was like oh they're so
nice this is so cool we got back in the
car
i posted about it that night and
somebody damned me was like they're
racist and send me all this
[ __ ] and i was in my head i was like i
wonder if this was a pr movie yeah i
know like they saw an asian girl like oh
thank you
maybe we got to do this but that's a
[ __ ] it's all time
but they're not closing they're just
changing management
yeah the father and son are still owners
of the pizza shop so it's one of those
things where
if you still buy from them you're still
putting money in their pockets but
they're not in charge of the day-to-day
management
they got a lot of heat on social media
too because they were uh
taking down a lot of comments about
people saying that they were racist and
then people call them out on that they
had to make a statement saying that they
wouldn't delete stuff on their instagram
right under their the company profile
it's terrible under the company yeah
be better being racist if you don't
count on a lot of the stuff that they
said
they doubled down on a lot of the stuff
that they said because there was some
backlash when
it first started and then they would
double down on it
and that kind of went away but now all
these things are resurfacing
during this time it's like it's just a
shame to see man
damn so we can't get that pizza no more
let's not get crazy
let's not take this at a time
[Laughter]
i'll still buy it you know it's like
you know yeah i don't support what you
don't you won't
oh i'm bringing dollar here yeah
the racism was mainly towards asians ah
see it's one of those things like they
do have delicious pizza and i do love
pizza but i don't think i like pizza
enough to
go buy it anymore if i'm being honest
you're out i'm out yeah
yeah i looked at it and it just sounds
like something
like the whole thing i was like where's
the actual real real racism
saying yellow dog that was like the
closest thing i i saw yeah but then i
did look up yelled at yellow doesn't
mean
coward too you know you know what you
yell you yellow belly whatever
yeah so i mean i don't know okay
i don't have too much feelings either
way yeah yeah i don't think i have
enough feelings where i i won't eat
their pizza anymore yeah cause you don't
have a dog in a fight
i mean a little bit i like i mean i'm
the only white person
that i employ and everyone else is asian
or black
so i don't i definitely don't [ __ ] with
racism are you right i think if it was
there if someone bought it
i'd eat it but i wouldn't go out of my
way to get it yeah
that's what i was trying to say it's
weird with chin because they're italian
right so it's like
yellow he's like i'm calling you a
coward i'm not saying yellow because
your skin
that's why you don't know what's stupid
what they were doing like yes
just business customer service is
terrible but
listen i listen to breakfast club and
charlemagne talk [ __ ] about white people
every [ __ ] day yeah
yeah i get his angle but yeah calling
white people white isis or vanilla ices
everything that's not right either
no it's like dude it's getting old man
like at some point you got to stop
like a lot of white people gave him a
lot of breaks so not all white people
are racists or bad people
i get sick of that i'm not going to stop
listening to charlemagne but that's his
perspective
for those italians it's like is it
racist
if i went to it and they were dropping
the n word and saying that
then i'm i all right i can't i can't
defend that but
as a small business owner in black lives
and
did their new york uh establishment get
raided or looted
and that's their perspective i get it
man if you don't have if you can't do
business because
the protest something they're probably
pretty upset i don't know if it's a
racist thing more towards a protest i
think it was an angry you think it's a
great issue
but again they're not dropping n-bombs
or things yeah they said saying
derogatory
terms towards asians if it's [ __ ] or
slanted or that's different yeah then
then i'll be honest that's for sure
because i was like i didn't know mutt
was a racist
there were certain terms in there that i
didn't even know was like some old
school
challenge it's like yeah that's what i'm
saying it sounds like oh it's just like
oh yeah mutt
but again but it doesn't like if they're
dropping trying to be italian i thought
that was more of like a derogatory term
for like biracial like black and white
people not necessarily i didn't even i
didn't even think that i thought mutt
was just like oh you're just calling
someone a dog
but if again if they would have went
blatant racist n words
[ __ ] all that [ __ ] i'm out man yeah but
this is like
all right just dumb customer service
yeah okay that's fair
i like that yeah where are you yeah but
but what the
mongrel yeah we're just monk that's
another thing that's not a word for like
a dog
is it she said that's another word but
you are you're a coward right
and but it's the lady wrote the dog of
no definable type of breed so it's just
is social media making it worse he's
like whoa the f i'm not saying that it's
a yellow dog
i'm sure that's the key word that made
them look racist because they use yellow
yellow yeah yellow dog i'm not into this
cancer culture i'm still buying their
pizza
makes sense all right
how about that when i get off stage with
the lap factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what this is from
a bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic song